[Music]
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
we're at the big 912 rally that Freedom
Works is putting on at the Capitol and
at the National Mall they did this last
year with a much bigger crowd and a much
more unified message of stop the
spending and turning out people in DC
this year the people we've talked to
seem much more animated against Obama
and against the Democrats they're
smaller a number but seems stronger and
spirit and at the same time the unifying
message of stop the spending seems to
have faded a little bit and people are
more interested in talking about
auxilary issues such as illegal
immigration
[Music]
you know I'm not a racist but I'm tired
of hearing the Miss black America
contest you can't you can't get in if
you're white tired of hearing about the
black colleges I'm tired of hearing
black black why'd you come out today
well we came out to show good people at
in black and white must unite because
this is like Wars the class war in
actuality the Democrats are trying to
show that the Tea Party people are
racist they're using the Truman trick
they making them out to be Dixiecrats
the mean you're speaking today what are
you gonna be speaking about I'll be
talking about the myth of racism and how
the progressives continue to keep
pushing the idea that Tea Party movement
is about racism has absolutely nothing
to do about race it's about Obama's
policies we're not supporting anybody we
just want people to listen to the people
the movements a truncated pyramid you
can't attack it because it doesn't have
a leader and that's that's a huge
frustration for the left stream media
thing they're like diapers they need to
be changed regularly okay we can
encapsulate it as communists can Kenyan
Muslim yes this is the salt of the earth
I would hand one of my youngest child
who's four years old to any person
walking down this procession and say
will you take care of my kid I'll be
back in a half hour well we're gonna
have a good time people are gonna
celebrate freedom they're going to send
a message to Washington that they insist
on some respect from this institution
behind us and frankly we have a
political elite and there are
Republicans and Democrats who think that
the countries they're different as they
please
and we the people have sat on our tails
and let them do that
it was Bush any better than Obama Bush
was better but not by much
if you could change one thing tomorrow
what would it big one law or one poly
banking belt a banking bill passed ago
[Applause]
do you think Obama knows the lyrics to
American Pie no you had the 912 Bradlee
last year it's back this year the crab
looks smaller but also more intense but
are they staying on the anti spending
message they are and what you need to
know about 912 is we now have probably
hundreds of 912 rallies all across the
country so people are taking the protest
back home and frankly that's the goal
that's a success story we're still
focused on the core economic issues on
the left is still trying to inject these
these other issues which are a diversion
and we're keeping them off the stage
so you're an infiltrator what are you
infiltrating Tea Party crashing the Tea
Party and where are you infiltrating
from we need to reduce government
spending by 43 percent that's just if
we're gonna balance revenues with
expenditures and that's gonna take
across the board and of course the
biggies Medicare Medicaid Social
Security defense absolutely out of Iraq
out of Afghanistan were nation-building
all around the world don't we have our
own nation to build do you agree that
America's national anthem is a terrible
song no no of course not
it couldn't be terrible it stands for it
shows what our country stands for
the beauty of the Tea Party movement is
watching it hold Republicans accountable
you know for all those people to think
that this is just 1994 all over again
those people came in in the pre-internet
era and they did not have this active
democracy at work that this
participatory democracy at work and in
1994 people didn't think that America
was going under this group of people if
you asked and think that we are going
down the road to degrees
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]